there are one or two sane people in
government I usually put Rand Paul at
the top of my list and uh yeah Rand
Paul's not happy about it I brought with
me the Omni
4155 pages
when was it produced in the dead of the
night 1 30 in the morning when it was
released
now people argue that it's
conservative's fault it's you don't have
the Christmas spirit somehow you're
holding up government well whose job is
it to produce this the people in charge
of spending the people in charge of both
of the parties when did they know that
this would be necessary well it's in the
law September 30th you got nine months
almost 10 months to produce a plan to
have a spending plan they weren't ready
on September 30th so they voted
themselves 90 more days they weren't
ready last week either so they voted
themselves another week and now we have
it at 1 30 in the morning this morning
but what's the clamor the clamor is to
vote vote now let's get it done why are
you standing in the way of spending well
the real question is this what is more
dangerous what is more dangerous to the
country
1.1 trillion dollars in new debt or is
Republican leadership likes to say oh
but it's a win it's a big win we're
getting 45 billion dollars for the
military so which is more important
which threatens the country more are we
at risk for being invaded by a foreign
power if we don't put 45 billion into
the military Are we more at risk by
adding to a 31 trillion dollar debt
I think the greatest risk to our
national security is our debt the
process stinks it's an Abomination it's
a no-good rotten way to run your
government
you know what's interesting is that
Mitch McConnell as you know is from
Kentucky
Rand Paul as you know is from Kentucky I
have a feeling these guys don't have
dinner that often
um yeah everything that Rand Paul said
there is true the way they frame
everything the time they have to do it
and then they try to jam it through and
nobody's read it and they send it to you
late and all of that stuff you know I I
obviously I like Rand Paul a lot and I
saw him in DC a couple weeks ago and we
interviewed him again
um it's interesting because and I've
sort of tried to say this to him
sometimes it's like he's kind of like
the same guy who accidentally got thrown
into the mental institution right so
everyone in DC Republicans who they're
all just awful everyone does all the
wrong things like they just don't care
nobody nobody is willing to take the
slings and hours and I'm talking at the
federal level because obviously I'm not
talking about the state level where
there are good things working Florida
um
but he's the guy who they accidentally
admitted to the mental institution and
he's trying to tell everybody guys guys
I'm not supposed to be here there's ways
better we can do this thing we don't
have to drug everybody we should try
some other therapies there's you know
okay and I know this guy's talking to
himself and this guy's whatever and but
and and he just but he's a glutton for
punishment but he's he's basically like
one man standing there as the tide gets
higher and higher going guys we're all
going to drown soon does anyone does
anyone want to get some flip-flops or
what do they call those things little
little things that go on the kids arms
not little floaties thank you uh here
here's a picture that Rand Paul tweeted
out that's the size of the bill
4155 Pages nobody has read that freaking
thing